[Music]
hey babies hey my babies what's up
congratulations the podcast we're back
it's the first ever 5th episode and
we're doing it we're doing it live well
this is live when I shoot it but it's
actually not live because it'll be when
you listen to it you know they say taped
live for later sometimes which is
basically like saying hey this is not
live but let's just pretend I'm in your
car or your cubicle talkin eeeh and
we're having a good time or maybe
wherever you are maybe you're just
sitting in your bed you listen to you're
listening to this podcast and I'm just
right next to you not even in a sexual
way even though we're in bed we're just
in like a chilling way right like like
if you're a guy and I'm a guy and then
we're just kind of hanging out looking
at each other and and having a
conversation and maybe not maybe the
TV's on and maybe we're just looking at
the TV but we're still having a
conversation and this is what we're
talking about and you're not doing the
talking and I am or if you're a girl
it's not sexual at all either we're just
kind of chillin doing the same thing
only only you're you don't have the guy
parts you got the the lady parts but it
doesn't even matter so um we're back
it's Monday night we're going to have
this out by the way everybody asks me
when's the next podcast when's the next
podcast a monday night monday night
monday night because it's been that way
for four weeks and it's going to
continue be that way
okay uh so it'll be there sometimes
later sometimes earlier but you'll have
it for your Tuesday that's that's the
idea is that you're going to have it for
your Tuesday your commute to work or
your commute to wherever the [ __ ] you do
you're gonna have it on Tuesday if you
wake up if you don't you died um so uh
so yeah so a big big week for me I shot
my special I shot my special for Netflix
and I'm allowed to announce it wasn't
allowed to announce it until I sign the
paperwork did it that's how those things
work usually and
it's going to come out in either May or
June I shot it in Vancouver I did it
with the Canadians Canadian the
Canadians were awesome and I love I love
Canada man i straight-up [ __ ] love
Canada aye aye aye aye just the
audience's are awesome from Toronto to
[ __ ] Vancouver man
Winnipeg been to Calgary been a [ __ ]
Edmonton you know I don't go to North
because I don't want to all of a sudden
you know freeze be like that the last
scene and [ __ ] The Shining where it's
just Jack Nicholson's head sticking out
of the [ __ ] snow and it but it's me
with a microphone by the way if you're
mad at me for ruining the shining you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and just watch it
already but yeah I love Canada Canada's
so cool man you get there first of all
everybody's got beards it's unbelievable
dude everybody's got upside-down head
longer hair than on their face than they
do on their head I fit in because I have
a beard some of the women have beards
and other women's don't have beards but
um yeah it's cool man they got like
seven million coffee shops which I love
they have coffee shops across from
coffee shops I was in a coffee shop and
I went to order coffee and they were
like would you like to try our coffee
shop and they let me into a different
coffee shop downstairs that was a
separate business that's very stupid but
that didn't obviously happen so save
your tweets for that but I love it man
it went well the second show went really
well the first show was okay but I had
some mic issues the mic cut in and out
which is like that's never happened in
my career and of course it happened the
first taping am i special and I couldn't
[ __ ] believe it man it cut out like
five times during the whole show and
they had to bring me a new mic in the
middle of the show dude in the middle of
the show
a stagehand comes out with one of those
[ __ ] Britney Spears mics on you know
how he has that's how they talk to each
other with their on their face which is
like the dorkiest thing ever I know it's
very convenient but if you have a
microphone near your face that you're
not holding a yo that's like like how
would you get [ __ ] like that in all
sincerity even if you the only person
you can have sex with is another person
with that microphone on because then you
identify with them and they're like yeah
we booked up these mics on anyway I want
to [ __ ] but you could never ever ever
meet somebody with that microphone on
and then have them sleep with you but
but they came out and they did it are
you know I rolled with it I don't know I
might use some of it in this special
because it was kind of funny but I have
like this whole Oracle that I'm trying
to do I'm telling this story man so I
probably use most of the second show
that's how it works that's how we do it
that's why we shoot - everybody shoots -
every single [ __ ] comedian shoots -
except for Sinbad that's what I heard I
heard Sinbad does one show when he tapes
his special and does two and a half
hours and then cuts one hour out of it
dude first of all I think Sinbad is
honestly one of the funniest [ __ ]
guys ever that dude kills me man to do
two hours on stage is unbelievable
two hours it stand-up not war dude
that's how long Wars lasts
that's unbelievable dude we've been at
war in the Middle East for two and a
half hours that's a so long if I did - a
half hours the crowd would check out
after an hour they'd be like okay all
right we were going to go home we have
to pay our babysitter's I feel like when
Sinbad's on rock and it's sweating so
hard using the towel murdering it people
people I feel like he murders it so hard
that after two and a half hours people
get out and they're like that was a
ripoff he only did 15 minutes that's how
funny I think he is so yeah so I shot it
in Canada went well awesome
drank so much coffee and water I didn't
eat sugar in Canada I was leaning his
[ __ ] onstage dude I was like Hugh
Jackman when he shot that scene in the
last the 47th Wolverine movie where he
fights that [ __ ] one guy and he's got
his shirt off and literally you can see
all the veins in his veins
he's got veins in his teeth I heard an
interview with with [ __ ] Hugh Jackman
and he was like yeah you know I didn't
eat any sugar I ate a lot of weight a
lot of vegetables and though I don't
need I don't need you know I eat a
little bit of carbs not the good carbs
huh not the good carbs huh we're talking
about maybe a little bit of brown rice
but no sugar for 75 years yeah having
had sugar since I was one just to train
for this yeah and then five days before
five days before I shot that same um I
didn't drink any water because I didn't
want to be heavy water weight so it was
just me skinny bouncer veins in my teeth
and foreign an Asian guy yeah yeah it
was unbelievable he looked amazing
realize the look in the mirror after
that and I thought yeah I'll never look
like this again yeah and I seven cakes
to make up for lost time
nah neither my Cavallo's lon
alright seven cakes and some cemento it
ate some cement tonight some wood huh
went out in the forest and just ate a
log cabin er I had a little Kevin
tonight what it said on which was cement
and seven cakes and I three people um so
uh yeah I was not that lean I was
basically looked like a regular guy but
a little bit leaner than Chris D'Elia
usually looks had to [ __ ] do it dude
had to do it to him you know I'm not
gonna get out there and look like some
[ __ ] I got it you gotta take care of
yourself you're gonna be on camera bro
uh so I did that and it was awesome I
can't wait for it to come out man on
fire well I know there's a movie called
man on fire but my [ __ ] special is
called man on fire um and so anyway look
for that put it in your [ __ ] Q is not
in the queue yet on Netflix but uh so
yeah I I love here's something I want to
tell you guys I love because I talk
about [ __ ] and about how [ __ ] is wrong
uh and about how I can you know I say
don't do this don't do that I want to
tell you some [ __ ] guy who deserves
an award for for being just great the
old [ __ ] man and I'm talking about
not sixth I'm talking like 70 75 80 that
just [ __ ] laughs all the time and
it's so happy and like open doors for
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
dude to live in this world see I'm
making it negative anyway to live in
this world and to get to that point and
to just be happy and call people like
son you know when they're not your son
or is like unbelievable this old man
held the door open for me and [ __ ]
Canada and it was Swedish [ __ ] and he
was the only person by the way they
didn't have a beard and he opened the
door for me and I and I said thanks man
and he set any laughed he [ __ ]
laughed he's 85 he was 85 years old and
he laughed cuz I said thanks it was cute
as [ __ ] man he was a little bundled up
it was freezing but you know Canadian he
looked like a guy that was like hiding
out right like he was it like he was in
the witness protection program but just
wound up in Vancouver Canada and laughed
I said thanks he goes haha and I got a
coffee it was awesome man I want to be
that guy I'm afraid I'm not going to be
that guy I'm afraid I'm going to be
[ __ ]
you know God bless Larry David's
hilarious well you kind of got to be
like that if you gonna be funny right
you got to be bitter and not that he's
85 he's not 85 but so that's who I love
do you get the award for the critic
crystally that's who I love that's what
I love um
god bless Canada maybe it's Canada that
makes you [ __ ] that happy maybe we
gotta move to Canada I don't know I
sushi in Canada I don't know if there's
good sushi in Canada or what it was okay
it wasn't bad um I sat down and I was
like hey can I have a menu and they gave
me a menu that had [ __ ] four things
on it at a sushi place four things and I
was like what's up with this menu and he
was like oh do you want the dinner menu
and I was like what's on the dinner menu
and he said I like everything and I was
like yeah give me the dinner menu then
and he gave me the dinner menu it had
7,000 things on it this [ __ ] if
I don't ask for the dinner menu I would
have had to get like some [ __ ] quail
eggs and that's it not it's not sushi
but you know what I mean um and and it
and and they were like doing me a favor
about like well you can have the dinner
even though it's not dinner yet you can
have the dinner menu that there's
something that I don't understand and I
won't ever understand I I will never
understand it and and and if I had a
restaurant now maybe this is why I don't
have a restaurant but if I have a
restaurant hey you can have any meal you
want I have at my restaurant at any
goddamn time do you know what I'm saying
when you get there I'd like eleven
o'clock and they're like oh we just
stopped serving breakfast oh really yeah
well let me ask you a question where'd
you where'd you [ __ ] put the goddamn
eggs then where'd you put them Oh away
away we're on Pluto away we're in the
[ __ ] fridge hey I got an idea
take them out oh I got an idea hope in
the fridge open the fridge use your
[ __ ] human arm grab those eggs take
mine
out the [ __ ] are you talking about
oh we just stopped serving breakfast you
can't have sliced tomatoes eat my dick
what what do you know it's 1101
oh it's 1101 we're sorry you can't have
this steel-cut oatmeal oh you got water
right you got heat you got the meal
right or did you ship it to Pluto
put the [ __ ] oatmeal in the water
heat it up Kim dude it like get over
your [ __ ] self what is it a money
thing
what do you saving seven dollars I'm
never going to a place again if I walk
in and I get a menu and they're like
Lipsy oh you better work you out when
you get there and they're like you
better order in five minutes because
they're closing the they're closing the
lunch menu oh oh [ __ ] okay don't don't
don't don't don't don't in thumb it's
like the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh god
what are you gonna get what are gonna
get what are you getting what are you
getting I get the ahi tuna salad I'll
get it or did we get it in quick enough
excuse me sir come over here I'll have
that I hate tuna salad please can you
please wring it rush run it to the
kitchen man we've got one minute left I
don't want to MIT I don't want him to
pack up the I don't need them ship in
the [ __ ] tuna to Pluto please that's
just so ridiculous dude I'll never
understand that if I have a restaurant
if I ever have a restaurant at
restaurant and I and not restaurant even
though that's what I said if I ever have
a restaurant dude it's going to called
it's gonna be called hmm I'm forgetting
lots of words in these sentences but
it's going to be called any time and you
go in you can get anything I have in the
goddamn kitchen at any goddamn time
unless we're out of it if we're out of
it then okay but also won't be out of it
cuz we're restaurant so annoying I don't
like to be
felt bad too when I'm a patron when I
walk in and I'm like uh who can you okay
well you know what I'm okay we can do it
for you
oh well just get McDonald's McDonald's
does it too sorry I can't have the
pancakes
by the way McDonald's closes breakfast
at like 3:30 a.m. with a [ __ ] who are
they serving only Marines who are they
serving [ __ ] bats the oh you you get
there at like 9:00 a.m. they're like mom
sorry dinner sorry we're serving dinner
ridiculous dude um yeah so uh that's not
in I'm not into it in Canada they have
these [ __ ] they're ahead they were
ahead of the game on the chip thing I
think or whatever it is here they'll do
like they I don't think they don't do
this in America maybe they do maybe I've
done it once or twice but in Canada
it'll be like y'all done and you'll be
like yeah I'll be like okay and you'll
give him your credit card and I'll be
like hold on to that we'll be right back
and then they come back they give you
the [ __ ] it's like a little handheld
device and they give it to you you slide
your credit card in and then and then
you tip on the thing and then the thing
prints out and then you rip it off and
you sign it I don't want to do the work
okay Canada I don't want to do that work
I'll give you the credit card you take
it back you do all the [ __ ] you God do
bring me back the paper I'll sign it and
give me back the credit card that's why
I don't go to these [ __ ] I don't go
to the what's that Benihana place is
that that place that would I cook in
front of you and there and some of the
places
Benihana that way some of the places go
a step further and they give you the
[ __ ] meat and you gotta fry it I'll
just stay home if I got a cook
what I got question for you what oh
that's like oh yeah you want buy a TV or
you just want to act out the shows by
yourself at your house hey come to the
movies come to it [ __ ] I'm gonna
mention them again because I mentioned
almost in every up every episo--
come to the movie instead of Tom Hanks
no will do to to Jacqueline because
we're on your jacket we're going to come
to Hugh Jackman movie you get to the
movie theater you be Hugh Jackman that's
what [ __ ] these Korean barbecue
places or whatever the [ __ ] are making
you do come to the Hugh Jackman movie
you'll be huge here you go
take your shirt off buckle these pants
here are some claws stop drinking water
go and go hey I'm Wolverine and we're
the Asian guys I've got a fight that's
not my job it's Hugh Jackman's job you
I'm gonna come to your cooking
restaurant you make me cook with [ __ ] I
need you for then guess what breakfast
is served any time anybody want eggs
even though at 6 p.m. I'm breaking rules
dude I'm drinking coffee I'm drinking
this caveman nitro cold brew coffee that
my buddy Tate Fletcher invented or
whatever and it's so good and I'm not
I'm not being paid for this he just gave
me a bunch and he gives me a bunch
whenever I need it want it zero calories
zero fat zero sodium zero carbohydrate
zero sugar zero protein I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I'm literally
drinking nothing but it tastes so good
it might be the best coffee I've ever
had
caveman nitro cold brew coffee so thanks
tape somebody [ __ ] tweet him and let
him know I said that [ __ ] um yeah so so
so I write down little notes to talk
about but I'm not really using them I
saw a thing up in Canada when I when I
when I was in there and it said it said
whoopsie I moved the microphone it said
it was like it's funny when you get to
these like like it's so funny when
you're a comedian and you get to these
cities and you see other comedians being
promoted and the way they're being
promoted it's always like a live it's
always like a little embarrassing seeing
your poster up because you're like oh
you're they use that picture and it's so
corny
it's so corny or whatever and then to
think of like Patton Oswalt having to
see my poster like that is like he's
probably playing bigger venues than I am
but you know what I mean like it's just
so like it's like man [ __ ] Gary Gulman
has to see me like that or whatever the
[ __ ] it's so funny dude and it done I
don't like it but it's it's part of the
game dude you got to be like that and
then but so sometimes you see other
Flyers for other people that aren't even
comedians like I saw one I saw one by
the way I saw one I was walking down the
street through a bunch of different
flyers and [ __ ] on it and there was one
of like four Brody Jenner and it was
like Brody Jenner is going to be at the
wherever it was you know whatever club
it was but dude okay I understand that
there's Instagram sensations and [ __ ]
and like and like girls that like are
popular Joe Rogan talked about it on
this last special about how there's
girls that are popular on social media
for just having an ass which is like
what they do you know and that's fine
and you got nine million followers or
whatever but then they become like these
like they go out and they get paid to
like go to clubs and and say I'm gonna
be at [ __ ] live come on out maybe
I'll [ __ ] yeah that's the mug that's the
vibe right
maybe I'll [ __ ] yeah that does that's
what that those girls are maybe I'll
come on out to the club maybe I'll [ __ ]
you and then you get there you don't but
uhm and so I saw one with Brody Jenner
which blew my mind I didn't know there
were guy versions of that like I get it
if you're the girl that's like come see
me come see my tits kinda in the
cleavage and then do some dudes are like
oh dude she's gonna be there do you are
go sir tits even though that's not what
they're saying out loud they're like in
their head they're like my boss your
tits but like
what is like that like your job is this
is your job if you do that poser
that's the job title I don't understand
but Brody Jenner did it
like I guess girls might go but like
what guys gonna go if Brody Jenner is
there I mean it's cool by the way dude
the dude is maybe the most handsome guy
in the world but like I just was like oh
my god what if that was your what if
that was what you do you show up to
clubs and people come to look at you and
don't before you even start loose with
the dude no they don't
I [ __ ] do jokes okay nobody's [ __ ]
going up to a [ __ ] John Legend
concert to see him they're going to
[ __ ] experience him
I'm gonna call my shows the crystal he
experience dude like it's a magic show
that blew my mind man you dude don't do
that
oh you're do you dude good job
to talk about the [ __ ] uh the Oscars
dude I didn't watch I don't watch award
shows it makes me it makes me
uncomfortable a little bit now I'm not
saying if I ever got nominated for some
[ __ ] I wouldn't go but it just makes
me uncomfortable when I'm not involved
and there's so many people they're just
you know congratulating each other which
it's fine I get it there's great actors
and actresses and [ __ ] Denzel I
didn't see the movie fences but you know
that dude killed it I gave you the bones
when he did that [ __ ] you know I gave
you a heart with a funky sand punch in
his chest
Denzel [ __ ] punches so many chests in
movies it's unreal
he did it to Viola Davis and they were
like you can't do that she's a woman
he was like mm it's not me it's the
character he [ __ ] punches so many
chests it's unbelievable chest punch
count that's like the [ __ ] John wick
body count for Denzel movies
what's his chest punch count if denzel's
in a movie and he doesn't punch
someone's chest it's not real movie that
it's not up for an award Academy is like
we you know it's great yeah we love
Denzel we didn't punch anybody's chest
so yeah
Oscars uh uh did it they were doing that
I don't watch it also like the Grammys
are just with the grant when the Grammys
happened I was like okay I can't I can't
watch any of them even though the Oscars
are wait a more though
but the [ __ ] Warren Beatty thing man
that people are talking about when he
[ __ ] up no I take that back he did not
[ __ ] up he did not [ __ ] up it's driving
me nuts everyone saying Warren Beatty
you know [ __ ] this all up well he
didn't do anything he just [ __ ] stood
there first of all this is the person's
fault it's whoever handed him the
envelope is that's whose fault that is
that's it that's the fault of the whole
thing whoever that guy is absolutely got
fired no doubt that guy had to get fired
or girl
secondly whose fault that is is Faye
Dunaway because she's the [ __ ] person
that said la-la-land then wave way down
the line it's Warren Beatty's fault he
stood there and he was confused because
it didn't say [ __ ] it said emma stone
lala land and for people that are like
well it didn't say you know the best
picture it said best actress it still
[ __ ] said lala land right he's an
actor that's what he does he's not a
[ __ ] comedian dude if a comedian was
up there
if Jimmy Kimmel was up there he probably
been like oh I got the wrong envelope
because he does this [ __ ] he stands in
front of crowds all day long and he
doesn't sweat under pressure
Warren Beatty is an actor he's not in
front of [ __ ] live crowds all the
time he's in front of a camera people
hand him lines literally and he says the
[ __ ] lines that he's handed that's
what he [ __ ] did that night by the
way he didn't even do it
Faye Dunaway did it right that's her
name right Faye Dunaway was like lala
land and then lala land came up it
wasn't [ __ ] Warren Beatty's house
house house it well it wasn't it wasn't
Warren Beatty's house you know but it
wasn't his do do I have a brain tumor
bro one time my uncle [ __ ] ate a
brownie and he spit it right out and he
said why did the brownies taste like
fish dude we [ __ ] lost it we were
like oh we were laughing so hard were
like what the [ __ ] you talking about
mouthful of brownies were all eating
them they tasted so good and like
brownies and he said what it says like
fish he literally spit it into his cup
and said why does it taste like fish do
you know what a brown you would have to
[ __ ] taste what the [ __ ] would you
put in a brownie to taste like fish what
would you put in a brownie fish [ __ ]
pills one time I was working out and I
was taking fish oil pills and a fish oil
pill exploded in my pocket the gym
cleared out dude I smelled like a
[ __ ] Barracuda it was awful I smelt
like a [ __ ] sockeye it was awful
chicks were looking at me like oh are
you a fish
by the way that's not a fart that's the
[ __ ] couch yeah man but my butt yeah
so now we tease my uncle like every
other weekend will be like as a brain
tumor from that [ __ ] fish brownie
every time we have a Gaeta brownie we
just taste like fish um was i saying
about the fish about the what I say
about the oh oh yes oh it's not Warren
Beatty's fault it's not his fault it's
like that scene in a Good Will Hunting
sign fall Martin I know I know it's not
your fault I know I know it's something
I know it's not your fault
I know I know me it's not a fault and
they starts crying that [ __ ] that scene
is awesome I really want to see that
great wall movie where the [ __ ] Matt
Damon fights the lizard guys I'm down
let me tell you something dude I'm a
hundred percent down for any movie where
a movie star has to [ __ ] fight
lizards lizard people with a bow and
arrow in is it China is that what's
called the Great Wall or no I don't even
know maybe it's just me I'm being racist
there's other Great Wall
dude just because it's a great wall then
they have to mean it's in China
that it's in China okay my producer
Chris is telling me it's in China so if
you think it's racist then it's him
the directors Chinese so there you go
it's the who Zhang emo that's his name
oh he directed the Beijing Olympics and
they give him this [ __ ] movie where
he fights lizards that's hilarious when
were the Beijing Olympics okay well
that's not as funny but still it'd be
funny if somebody was like yeah hey yeah
we're gonna have a movie Matt Damon he
fights a bunch of lizards who should we
get you want to get like Guy Ritchie or
something I'll just get the guy who
directed the Olympics dude but uh oh god
I don't know I think we should probably
get Peter Berg no no no
we're gonna get into the Olympics do you
see how he [ __ ] covered the torch
Carrie um you know I don't know man
dad does Oscars though people just
[ __ ] love to write the jokes they sit
on Twitter and love the wretched jokes I
try I did I've done that a few times but
I couldn't do it today earlier the other
day um couldn't do it the built the Bill
Paxton thing was crazy man that that I
woke up and I just saw my my buddy post
a picture of his Bill Paxton was like oh
yeah he was awesome in aliens and I was
like oh I I didn't know um I didn't know
I was like ah that's that's odd he's
supposed to my Bill Paxton and then I
[ __ ] saw all everybody posting about
him that's just crazy I saw him like a
month ago at the grocery store he looked
good he looked [ __ ] you know good he
was old lively and [ __ ] people being
nice to him and he was like being he was
like being a like such a nice celebrity
and [ __ ] I I told him that like I was
like ah yeah I love your work you're
great and he was like ah thanks a lot
and then and then yeah and then that was
it it was just nice as [ __ ] man he was
so [ __ ] funny man he was so good in
every he was so good
that was a [ __ ] that was a wild man I
just can't I just it was in hard surgery
right it was while he was in heart
surgery surgery something like that
that's so [ __ ] up man kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up you know think about his
family or whatever that whatever I mean
good honor me to be a downer but um you
know I was just thinking about like all
of the movies that he was in like even
in True Lies he was so [ __ ] funny and
True Lies you know like everyone thinks
about alien or Terminator God he's been
at some
[ __ ] movies you look up these guys on
IMDB and you realize have been like 237
movies they like so many credits but
yeah sorry that's what the [ __ ]
Oscars is let me think of that talking
about that but yeah I want to remind
everybody about anyway recipes recipes
bill paxton man that was we lost a good
one man too soon
the I want to remind everybody that you
can hashtag the podcast though and and
ask me questions cuz I'm gonna be doing
that a little bit more the good ones and
[Music]
there was one that brought something to
my attention today or this past week
this tweet from I can't [ __ ] make it
bigger these [ __ ] iPhones to [ __ ]
iPhone when you when you go to save a
picture and it and it goes to blurs out
the rest of the [ __ ] the smarts clay
[ __ ] it no I want to or when you want to
move an app and it's like it keeps
getting into soft focus all right here's
the here's the guy's name Shawn but then
his [ __ ] Twitter name is Deng boy ten
change it Deng boy ten it's cool change
it and he said can you make can you make
fun of chief Keef's bio in the upcoming
congratulations pod now that's going to
be up to me bro you don't [ __ ] ask
for requests you know maybe next time
you like
have you seen this you know mean [ __ ] of
my jukebox bro what am i joke box Deng
boy ten change it ah now I'm kidding
with you uh Chief Keef his bio and then
I read it just now well I'm actually
yeah and I'm glad that this guy brought
it to my attention because I just reread
it first of all is the email to EEP
this is the bet let me do that later no
let me do that now his email for booking
is booking shows features and ggp beats
at gmail.com that's the [ __ ] longest
but imagine typing that in imagine being
like I want to book this guy [ __ ]
alright and typing and then going back
and looking look it shows features and
ok and then typing the rest of the GGO
is a to geez GG and then a P or just
beats go back P beats at gmail eat my
[ __ ] dude come on
who's [ __ ] Booker is that as a worse
agent ever um imagine saying that yo you
want to want to book me booked me at
booking shows features and Gigi PB beats
at gmail.com people be like huh anyway
is lambda bam bam bam bar whatever the
[ __ ] you say this is he a mumble rapper
I think he's a mumble rapper dude
whatever he I don't think he's
technically a mumble rapper but I don't
know I don't know and maybe it that's
racist but all these new rappers are
mumble rappers to me but this is by oh I
gotta go bye first of all okay man I
mean I I can't when I see [ __ ] like this
I literally have to sit down I don't
even know what what the funniest way is
to say this but I'm just gonna read it
okay I can't
why do rappers have to have I know this
is hacky I this is hacky but why do
rappers have to have more names than 45
people dude okay alright so this is what
the [ __ ] bio says I gotta go by Sosa
auto or auto or low or or or twice I
don't know or or so or two or Almighty
booking
shows features and G GPB beats at
gmail.com book anyone of those guys I
got a go by Sosa auto or auto or low or
or so or two or Almighty dude there's a
typo in his bio or or so he wrote ort
dude he went or overboard dude and then
his [ __ ] Twitter handle is Chief Keef
and then when you look at it on top of
that you know how like you can put your
name as something on Twitter and not
just your Toretto it's glory boy he dude
you don't get to have all the names I
gotta go bye dude hey what what's the
guy's name again
oh well I mean Chief Keef but I call
them Sosa hot oh and then you could buy
you can call my auto or low or so or tow
or all you know if you're getting really
crazy almighty and be like oh I just
used to call him glory boy oh no that's
okay too but anyway if you want a book
I'm go to booking shows features at ggp
beats at gmail.com oh really oh really I
can do all that oh go [ __ ] yourself dude
and then his website is glow gang world
wide calm hi bye dude so much to
remember so much to remember dude
reading his bio is like being in an
escape room there's so much to remember
dude yo I go by Sosa auto or auto or low
or or or so or two or almighty or glory
boy or chief keef anyway you can book me
a booking shows features and Gigi PB
beats at gmail.com or hit me up on my
website glow gang world wide calm what
dude
imagine whenever I hear something like
this whenever I see something I just I
think of my dad reading it literally my
dad would die if he read this he's 68 he
would die he would be like no I can't I
can't I can't I can't I can't his brain
would break he would eat a brownie it
would taste like fish and he
oh my god dude unbelievable he's not a
glories not our mumble rapper but dude
mumble rappers do it Emmet's a members
amendments up him an amendment amendment
lemon amendment aminute similar feminine
feminine chimin amendment amendment
bloom an amendment imminent no this is
my hit Mamina Mamina Mamina Mamina
Mamina Pamina geminate banana lemon a
lemon in an Internet this is Iggy Iggy
kick F F up in the net ha ha No thank
you very much I go by so Sado what is
that even
so Sado I know I'm looking up that's it
dude I'm looking up Chief Keef I got to
look up chief Keef's [ __ ] I will
never know how to spell chief by the way
not that a rapper would spell it the
right way glory boy came up here we go
ah man oh wow Oh first one I looked at
Jessica Alba I'm ready to stop being a
thought huh by the way I feel like Chief
Keef I read something about him that he
like he's a real tough [ __ ] so I
hope he doesn't come after me he sings
that song that's that [ __ ] I don't like
even that way even that is saying you
saying too many words in the in the
sentence that's that [ __ ] I don't like
you can just say I don't like and then
the thing but whatever it is [ __ ]
cheeseburgers that's the thing I don't
like is this way I like cheeseburgers
this
that's the thing I don't like oh this is
the best this is the best to glory boy
chief key aka Sousa auto or auto or Lolo
or cocoa or low so or such a solo this
is the best [ __ ] tweet you got games
on your phone
question mark what it's there's a link
hold on let me look at the link you got
games on your phone how does the lessee
I pay for this oh my god it's literally
just a selfie the link how [ __ ] funny
is this [ __ ]
you got games on your phone and then
[ __ ] selfie yes matter of fact I do
what was up though with that his 2012
album is called finally rich finally
rich he can't be that old oh man let's
see Keith Chief Keef age what if I
looked up Sosa Otto's age 21 years old
and that the [ __ ] album came on 2012
think I was 12 years old
finally rich mom okay change my pants
finally rich imagine being like c21
5 that was 5 2012 is [ __ ] 5 years ago
imagine being 16 and saying finally
about anything even if it was like
raining the whole time and then it was
sunny you couldn't be like finally
people in Seattle will be like
[ __ ] it's only been 16 years of
rain finally rich that's that [ __ ] I
don't like waiting for money for 16
years destice Chara don't write oh my
god dude
I'm [ __ ] dying so Sato so Sato what's
going on dude takes me for a long time
to get rich Warren Buffett pride took
him a long time finally rich to a 16
year finally rich at
years old finally rich can I use that
can I can still trying to eat the money
literally no no honey put that down
that's his mom finally I got money - II
can't change my diaper my I want kaki
that's not [ __ ] I don't like mom the
cartoons went off that's that [ __ ] I
don't like
finally rich at [ __ ] eight years old
hey mommy died got their boys in the
schoolyard are really messing with me
this this [ __ ] I don't like Mac have my
Baba that's that [ __ ] I do like Oh bro I
mean come on this is what this podcast
is oh my god Chief Keef oh there there
so so Auto there there's low work on
your website glory hole gang calm or
whatever the [ __ ] it is oh my god dude
oh my god let's look at more tweets from
Chief Keef the people that respond to I
love how people will just respond
husband you got games on your phone
husband
[ __ ] you get games on your phone husband
oh dude are you [ __ ] insane man all
of it this is what rappers do a lot of
rappers do this all of their tweets are
just links to their [ __ ] Instagram
man [ __ ] rest up bankroll
that's a tweet rest up bankroll well
after you're finally rich dude you'd
figure your [ __ ] money needs a rest
oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I was laughing hard
mumble rappers got it dude that's so
crazy
it's all so hacky to talk about this but
I just can't I don't understand it they
just [ __ ] are they actually saying
things I don't know I don't know if
they're actually saying sentences pen
pen pen pen I get it that the panel
looks like the [ __ ] a BMW car and
that's what he's saying
pen pen pen pen older dude ah this song
[ __ ] it goes hard though I mean you
got it
you gotta say it does go hard does he
say salad bar in it I feel like he does
say salad bar in it I don't know
sellable I think he goes cinnabar I
don't know but but this another comedian
Joe Mande he [ __ ] put up this thing
on Twitter or Instagram is so funny he
did like this breakdown of what he's
actually saying and he just shows the
images of what the [ __ ] and I think you
put a salad bar in there I don't know
but it's so funny but you should look at
it up look it up [ __ ] man
god damn I'm old that's what that means
I'm old I am old because I'm looking at
the 19 year old 20 year old artists and
I'm like what that's what that means my
dad told me once when I was a kid I said
dad you don't like this music and he was
like no not really I like like you know
Frank Sinatra and [ __ ] and also the
Beatles and whatever I was like but this
is cool why don't you get it and he was
like it's gonna happen to you too
he said you're gonna have kids one day
and they're gonna be listening to stuff
and I'll never forget the [ __ ] thing
he said they're gonna be listening to
music and it's gonna be like this oh and
I was like no music will never be like
that he said probably and it is it is
that's a song that's the song that's a
song by like [ __ ] DJ mouse mouse or
some [ __ ] you know uhm but yeah dude
it's crazy man how it happens what the
[ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] I don't have
kids now but what what when I do have
kids what are their kids going to be
listening to just like some just
probably just like ocean sounds it's got
to revert back to like or like some
classical [ __ ] do it I can't imagine
what the [ __ ] if we get to what the
[ __ ] a music gonna be like in 80 years
I mean I think about that [ __ ] for real
dude 20 years ago for the people that
are my age on this podcast 36 years old
20 years ago imagine if a [ __ ]
designer song came out now that then
deliver what a [ __ ] took this is a
crazy person I don't know another person
asked me I don't remember who was but I
saw it on the you can hashtag
congratulations pod and I will look
through them and I will pick some to
answer another person asked me what my
first joke was that I told onstage and
it was at the haha cafe in Los Angeles
California
um legit show legit joke
that I actually did was about took the
show 24 and Jack Bauer and I was like
how I loved it I loved watching the show
and I would talk about how like Jack
Bauer was always in a rush no matter
what the [ __ ] it was he was always in
that tone and like you like is he like
that on everyday life and I would be
like I need a haircut I need it now that
like that was the joke that he would
walk into a haircut and [ __ ] kick the
door down I mean that's so stupid
neither to think about it but that was
my first like joke I think I did on a
show show not open mic open mic I don't
even remember
but um yeah man I would open with that
for [ __ ] like that's so weird dude so
funny to think about that [ __ ] oh my god
yeah so that was what first dude that's
it that's all I got for you guys we're
rounding out about 50 minutes it's like
our average they might get longer as I
get a little bit better
but thanks for listening and also rate
and review the show please on iTunes
that would be helpful
try to stay relevant and you get these
numbers up because if I'm gonna be doing
this [ __ ] every Monday it's got to grow
otherwise [ __ ] um yeah so I
would appreciate it if you rated it and
tweeted about it and told your friends
honestly and made instagrams about it
and and that's a that's that you can
hashtag congratulations pod I will
answer
check out my check out my special on it
on Netflix called incorrigible I have
another one coming out in either May or
June on Netflix so anticipate that and
oh I got my dates Chris D'Elia calm
there my tour dates I'm going to
Milwaukee I'm going to Madison I'm going
to I'm going everywhere I'm going to
Australia I'm going to West Palm Beach
I'm going to Tempe I'm going to
Baltimore I'm going and they're played
Baltimore before a Long Island I got a
bunch of dates coming up so go look
Atlantic City Virginia Beach some in
North Carolina anyway check it out check
it out so that's it and my name is Chris
D'Elia you have been listening to
congratulations
[Music]